[Music]
hello and welcome to how the light gets
in and our session the age of
independence so arguably we're now more
independent than we have ever been
and yet there was a time when we lived
in our local communities
often having the same occupations as our
parents and not moving more than a few
miles from that location in our
lifetimes
but globalization
education
different forms of politics have made it
possible for people to transform their
lives and to move around the world
they've often found opportunities that
they wouldn't have otherwise dreamt of
they have freed themselves from some of
the accidents of their birth and
circumstances
so is this a good thing
we're going to be looking at that
question and wondering
is it always a benefit that we're more
independent
has it actually led us to feel more
ruthless
less connected perhaps rather lonely
should we be wary of this new form of
independence that's going to be the
topic of this session we're going to
pursue it
with a glittering set of speakers who
are joining us online
so let me introduce them to you
we have
john milbank who is one of the most
prolific
british theologians living today he's a
regular writer and collaborator with
slavor zizek he's published a large
number of books and for this session in
particular the one he would direct you
to is the politics of virtue written
with adam patz
also joining us
we have deidre mccluskey she's a
distinguished professor of economics and
history emerita at the university of
illinois she has written an enormous
number of uh very impressive books
covering
the human side of economics if i read
her right she's someone who's
just as
impressed by adam smith's theory of
moral sentiments that she is with the
wealth of nations and of her books uh
perhaps the best known for this occasion
is her 2019 why liberalism works
and then finally we've got i'm very glad
to say jasmine abdel majid who is a
social commentator and also trained as a
mechanical engineer
she was born in sudan and raised in
australia and like most australians she
ended up coming to london
working on a stream
she's been working on a string of
engineering jobs i've seen her
uh
building race cars and on oil platforms
so she was a very serious engineer but
it's now become a very important
cultural commentator and she's known for
encouraging greater secular
understanding of islam so thank you all
of you for joining us speakers
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
invite each of our speakers to set out
their stall if you like to make a short
pitch for their way of addressing the
question that we are
beginning with and we're going to pursue
in further depth
should we be wary
of our new form of independence
and i'm going to ask first of all john
if he will take it away and give us
three minutes on this topic john um yes
i think we should be wary but i'd like
to say at the outset
that i don't see an opposition between
our social embeddedness and our
individual development
in fact to the contrary i would say we
can't develop as individuals unless
we're socially embedded
if we're just left to ourselves we have
nothing we don't really acquire an
identity at all
we have to have a legacy we have to grow
up in a family in a community we have to
be told the stories of the past
and then we start to
appropriate those things
in our own way so that actually people
with very secure backgrounds are
precisely the people who do more develop
as individuals without that supposing
you have a very weak family background
a very poor community a very uh
deficient sense of inherited identity
what happens well then i think you're
actually at the mercy of forces in
the present you're at the mercy of
your peer group
of uh advertising of the markets of
state control and and and so on you have
no kind of critical distance from that
so that even when you think you're
making your own choices you often um
actually aren't and so there's a kind of
oscillation between being controlled by
outside forces
and a kind of narcissism that you just
um you're throwing back on your own will
and reflecting who you are and actually
if if you are a narcissist you can't
really be an individual you can't it's
just a kind of empty attempt to retreat
to the mother's womb you don't require
um um you know strong individual
characteristics um at all
now the second sort of uh big contrast i
want to resist is i don't want to say
oh modernity is all about individualism
and independence and the past was all
kind of cozy and organic and that was
great on the contrary i want to question
the idea that modernity is completely
individualistic i think that if you look
at the modern world you find contrast
that some places are much more
individualistic than others i think
maybe the united states is the most
individualist place but it
look at france for example where
everybody's sure they want to be
independent they want to go to paris and
be successful but they tend to retain a
little house back home they tend to
retire to their origins and there's a
kind of strong symbiosis between the two
so what i'm protesting against is
hyper individualism that i think has
possibly increased ever since the 1960s
and i think in the end this reduces
people's ability to become in individual
john thank you so um
certainly
uh some things that you're prepared to
see is uh good developments of
independence but lots of worries about
it going too far to see it in excess
so yes deirdre if i cannot turn to you
and ask the same question should we be
wary about independence or is it an
unalloyed good well in the uh
in the
first place our
modern life is there this very
medium shows
is not in
is not
independent it's
it's highly
connected
um and and i
don't think it's only for the for the
for the
for the rich and after all american
tv shows of rather low quality appear
all over the
world
um and and so
in trade in in
in all kinds of
occupations high and low
we're connected
so that
as john
says the
uh
the idea of
a
extreme
individualism is
i think exaggerated i think it's
exaggerated
historically over the
long run
in fact in ancient times in the middle
ages for example and certainly
in the uh in
roman and greek and for that matter
chinese and south asian times
there was a lot of movement of ordinary
[Music]
people they were they were not in fact
confined to their own villages as we
tend to think in our
junior school
vision of the
of the middle ages
so i
and i certainly agree with john and i've
emphasized
um
this on my own
that the economy and uh our
psychology
is
embedded as the sociologists say as
adam smith i always cross myself
good for you i'm an anglican so i i it's
learned
to take the whole thing very s seriously
in adam smith's other book
he emphasizes this over and over again
that you can't be a flourishing
individual if you're not inside a uh
a sus a
a
a society and i would emphasize as
an economist and economic historian but
you can't be a flourishing individual
easily
unless you're in
a flourishing economy
so i'm i'm
very much in favor of economic growth
and i do not think
that it causes um
people to be
sad and isolated
good thank you okay so
some positive vision to it there
yes man can you continue on this theme
and give us your your view should we be
wary or should we be encouraged where
are you standing on this it's
interesting when i first started
thinking about this idea of the age of
independence i wondered what we meant by
the concept of independence right
because if we have a look at this
current situation that we're in
curvature 19 for example
it became very clear that we were
incredibly interdependent as say people
living here in the uk because our supply
chains were global right we could you
know everything the food that we get the
infrastructure that we use the
manufacturing i mean my partner can't
get a nintendo switch because the
factories in wuhan you know have been
closed for months or whatever but the
reality is is that we have the sense of
independence that is actually removed
from the reality of it and i think
that's really important to tease out
what we're actually not what we're
talking about is a value rather than a
material reality and then the question
becomes well what value
how how do we distill that value and
what is it that we actually want out of
that value right i think of myself as an
incredibly independent person all right
it's a part of my identity it would be a
way that i would describe myself if i
was talking about what makes you know
yas mean but
i also grew up you know in a sudanese
family in a very collectivist culture
and balancing those things has
been
an interesting
you know it's been a cause of tension
and i bring this to the personal because
i think the the
the micro version of this plays out in
lots of different ways so
when we think of what it means to be
individualistic are we saying um or what
it means for a society to be
individualistic are we talking about
agency because i've moved numerous my
parents even though they're the most
collectivist people they moved they left
their family in sudan and moved across
the world to australia does that make
them less collectivist is that action
than one of an individualistic choice or
society or is that one that's actually
about them protecting the collective
you know nuclear family that they're a
part of
for me i then moved from my family to
perth and then to melbourne and then to
london all to follow particular jobs but
perhaps also for my own family unit and
so i i do think it's interesting when we
think about
whether we're the split between in um
doing things
prioritizing the individual versus
prioritizing the collective and what
does it mean to perhaps do both and john
talks about resisting the binary and i i
think that it's important in all of
these conversations to resist the binary
but also
tease out the nuance of well
what is the unit of collectivism that we
care about is it a uh biological family
unit
is it a interest group unit is it a
nationalist unit is it an ethnic unit
and i think actually what's happening is
that that unit is changing over time it
used to be that we were collectivist
just about you know our ethnic unit and
our physical unit and now that's shifted
and we haven't and perhaps the challenge
is how do we show
that it is important to have an element
of collectivism that we choose rather
than one that is just by happenstance to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you